any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
i want to conclude with uh the three
questions i ask all of my
uh guests and um and i think
you know there's no one i'd rather ask
this about than than you right now
and so we'll start with one that is you
know we're getting awfully religious
today but i
i can't help it it's something i think
about all the time uh maybe just one
second before i go there i think
one of the things i'm helping to do on
the into the impossible podcast and with
my own research
is uh construct what galileo's uh most
maybe it's his third or fourth
uh book that people really know about
called the assayer el sagitori
and it means uh the assayer someone who
tests something
like if you want to see if this is gold
you don't need
gold to test if it's gold you take a
piece of stone called a touchstone
and you rub it on there and it makes a
mark the stone has no value
but it allows you to see the wealth of
value that may be there or maybe lying
to you
so i've started this kicking around this
idea of a fellowship
for all of those theorists across the
quad from you
that are and and at the institute for
advanced study and i've had all these
people on they're all friends of mine
juan maldasena
um having nema akame
i love these guys john prescott beyond
next week your
late friend uh stephen hawking's
colleague leonard milano was on
but but i always think about you know
this question why are there so many
theories of everything
why are there so few experiments of
everything
and i said well there actually are a lot
of experiments but no one is looking at
the data
that already exists so if you hadn't
happened to like look through the pan
stars data
or you know if somebody hadn't thought
to look through you know the data when
pulsars were discovered in other words
it's data is abundant and cheap it's
like software
uh but you know how many i know facebook
came out of uh harvard right
but uh but very few cell phones have
come out of harvard
in other words it's easier to produce
software and theory in my analogy than
hardware and testable assays
so um so i'm trying to cultivate this
notion that people should look at data
that already exists
rather than coming up with a new theory
of everything that has some beautiful
properties of it
i agree i and i have an essay uh beware
that is titled beware of theories of
everything yes scientific american i
highly highly recommend yeah we're going
to have a link to it in the nuts i'll i
i advocate exactly your point yeah
okay final questions uh these all relate
some way to
uh to these theories of creativity and
imagination which
uh nobody exemplifies better than you so
the first one has to do with what is
known in hebrew as a zava ah
an ethical will so alfred nobel when he
created the nobel prize he said
he had no kids he had no wife and he
said i want these to go to people
who have caused the greatest benefit to
humanity
via their invention or discovery in
physics chemistry etc
um and of course it dates back to the
bible and jacob blesses his sons as they
did in last week's torah portion for
those that are playing along at home
uh but uh but the notion and the book of
deuteronomy is basically moses's last
will and testament
um and uh the question is for you what
would you put in your
in your ideological will in your in your
ethical will not your material will
uh but uh but what would you put in your
ethical will to benefit
the millions of people that count you as
not their biological father of
avi in that sense but their ideological
inspiration
yeah the one i was asked this question
actually by the harvard gazette you know
the pravda
at harvard university and what is the
one thing you would like to change about
the world
and my answer was i would like my
colleagues to behave
more like kids to be driven by their
curiosity
not to worry about making mistakes we
talked about all of these
and to be guided by
um what you know nature educates us
um and it's not about our egos
it's not about us getting honors rewards
prizes likes on twitter it's not about
all of that
it's about figuring out how things work
in the world and by the way i should say
sometimes
religion is viewed as an antithesis to
science like
but it's not the case because if you
were to figure out how the world works
you can appreciate it more it's just
like
looking at the watch and figuring out
how it works you know if you just look
at the outside
of a watch you know it doesn't look as
impressive
and so i you know if you want to be at
all as to what reality is
uh the best way to do it is to pursue
science because that gives you the mo
the highest resolution image of the
thing that you care about
right and so to me science is really
the way forward that's the way to change
our preconception
uh unfortunately what happens right now
is
because you know of some circumstances
in the history of
particle physics where you know the
super conducting super collider
project was cancelled back in the 1980s
there was a long hiatus a long period of
time where theoretical physics did not
receive
new data and that led
a new culture in where data is not
needed
you you don't want the you know you can
work on things that are not falsifiable
it's a post data
a post data environment like
deconstructivism you know posts
and it's even justified by philosophers
you know in some books
that are written and i find that
dangerous to the
spirit of modesty of learning
from the data what the world is rather
than believing
you know that we can come up the only
way we can come up with what reality is
is you know if we live in a simulation
as some people suggest
you know to me it's like being on drugs
let's put it this way
you can imagine that you have a billion
dollars
or that you have even 200 billion
dollars
you are wealthier than elon musk okay
uh you can imagine that fine
you can sit in your room and enjoy the
idea
but if you go to the atm machine and
check
your balance that will give you a
reality check and will educate you that
you cannot have that dream and you
cannot have that
wonderful idea that is so appealing and
that you can play with and have all
kinds of ideas of what to do with the
money and so
because there is a reality check and
that to me
you know is an important lesson because
we can be
bankrupt in terms of our ideas if we
never test them against an atm machine
which is experimental data yeah yeah
very good i always think about
uh the the meaning of the word science
is knowledge and the meaning of you know
torah or whatever is
wisdom as teacher is something very
different and
that wisdom requires humility and
knowledge doesn't right you can have
wikipedia has a lot of knowledge
i'm working with some friends on a
project i'm calling you know artificial
galileo or ai galilei i
i o uh about you know basically taking
all of his written words
and there's hundreds of thousands if not
a million words that he's written
putting it into you know gpt-3 and
churning out and see what you get and
maybe he can be a better teacher
of you know galilean relativity than
even brian keating it's hard to believe
okay
next statement is uh is uh relates to
something i think you'll get a kick out
of i had on the show
uh so this is the into the impossible
podcast arthur c clarke center for human
imagination curiosity is our
key uh byproduct here and i had on
uh carl sagan's widow as i mentioned her
name is ann durian
and i asked her this question i'm gonna
ask it to you i said in the movie 2001 a
space odyssey
uh there's a scene in the opening
moments which is based on arthur c
clarke's book
where these apes come upon this this
monolith in the savannah
of africa and they start hitting it and
they start bashing it and there's
nothing they can do with it they
you know they try to do all sorts of
things they can't get any extract
anything from this object then later it
appears like on the surface of the moon
and and and it seems to be like a time
capsule a billion-year-long time capsule
put by an ancient
technologically advanced civilization
and i asked andrew and i'm going to ask
you too
what would you put on a billion-year
long-lasting time capsule but she said
to me i already did that
i said what are you doing and she said
on the voyager uh one spacecraft carl
sagan
uh you know encrypted this this record
that uh that with her brain waves and uh
when she had just fallen in love with
carl it's quite poignant
and uh and also sounds of earth and
birds and
and apes or whatever and music from
around the world is actually the first
example of what's called
ethnomusicography or
world news anyway don't ask you avi what
would you put on an umua of your own
to travel and ply our galaxy for the
next billion years what piece of wisdom
or
time capsule content would you put on it
in it around it
well i would i would make nork's
spaceship i would put
a very advanced computer with ai and a
3d printer
and hopefully by the time we launch it
we would understand how to create
synthetic life in the laboratory there
are several people trying to do that
including colleague of mine jack shostak
here
a nobel laureate at harvard uh so
i would do that and then whoever finds
it
can use that machine to create life as
we have on earth and
that's much more informative than you
know a golden record who cares who the
beatles were you know like
i don't think okay let's put it this way
i don't think that we are so
accomplished that we are worthy
i mean it will be actually humiliating
if they look at us and say and laugh
you know they would say what are these
primitive creatures doing uh
but if you can have the information of
how to recreate what we have here
and launch it into space that would be
great yeah now i should say that
you know you might ask was there is
there any possibility that we will find
if there was a civilization
before us technological let's say a
billion years
ago would we find any evidence the
answer is no because there is geological
activity on earth and
anything that was here more than 100
million years ago was turned around and
mixed in
so if there were computer terminals on
earth they were churned up
and they are now deep in the in the
interior of the earth we can't really
tell
uh so if you want to leave a a something
like
a stature that they would indicate that
we were there
you want to put it on on a surface that
doesn't have geological activity and
you know the moon is an example yeah i
mean the only thing that happens on the
moon is that there are
impacts that you know they go 10 meters
deep but not much more than that
but other than that i mean the moon is a
museum it collects all the things that
fall on it
and by the way there is a plan to go
back to the moon as far as i'm concerned
the most exciting thing we can do
is just go around and see if there is
any evidence for
some technological debris that collided
with the moon yeah a year ago exactly we
had an event here with paul davies who i
know you know
and jim benford and they had it was
called is e.t
lurking in our own uh celestial
neighborhood
and they talked not only about the
surface of the moon as this ideal
you know kind of desiccated environment
in which anything could survive for
very long periods of time but also these
trojan asteroids these asteroids that
are
tiny little balls of you know kind of
rubble piles but some are solid and
you could put something there if you
wanted to observe and lurk
perhaps but uh but yes it's very uh so
it's very good that we
i'm just afraid we're gonna put it on
like you know this little disc you know
little usb drive and they're gonna be
like all right
and they'll say thanks but we we already
discovered string theory thanks very
much
by the way i should tell you that the
reaction of my colleagues to um
being a rock yeah you know that to me
reminds me of what a caveman would have
said
if you were to present the caveman with
a cell phone because
he would seeing rocks all of his life he
would say
well it's a shiny rock and and then you
know it's the same reaction
that yeah yeah
it reminds me of the there's a there's
an old joke of you know these uh
people are doing excavations in the in
the middle east somewhere and
and they go to uh they go to some
country or maybe it's asia they
they dig under they find like copper
wire
it looks like copper wine they say oh
this is evidence that we had underground
you know cables carrying power and
ethernet or whatever
and then some israeli guy says big deal
look over here
and the archaeologists say there's
nothing there and they say ah yeah
obviously they had
they had wi-fi communication they didn't
need a wire
okay just one thing i wanted yeah
um there was a seminar at the harvard
that i attended along with uh a sort of
mainstream conservative astronomer that
you know
worked on rocks in the solar system or
is like and as we were walking out of
the seminar the the guy was saying to me
and i will not mention the name
he was saying i wish it never existed
it's so weird i wish it never existed
now
to me you know that i cannot hear that
thing because
how can a scientist say about observed
facts i wish they never
i mean obviously they come in conflict
with what he had
thought about all the objects in space
but
you never say that you say great there
is an anomaly let's
figure out what it is you know you know
cosmologists we've been
thrilled to find something that never
existed
indicates what the nature of the dark
matter is you know like that would be
fantastic if we see evidence for an
anomaly that indicates
that so scientists should be grateful
for
any evidence coming their way even if it
is surprising and
unfortunately a lot of colleagues are
just looking for evidence that confirms
what they already
knew that's right and they lose that
child i would say i agree with you avi
you know scientists are like children
i've got a blessed to have children
and you know they're curious they smile
they play they're also very selfish they
don't like to you share their toys
they don't like to share credit you know
so it's like scientists we have to
balance
the good aspects i asked um obviously
i'll you know ask all my guests these
questions i asked barry barish the same
question
and he said curiosity is what i'd like
to transmit
uh to to future generations because uh
we get such a negative
notion of curiosity what's this famous
saying
curiosity killed the cat curiosity is
dangerous it's mendacious it's it's it's
it's perhaps you know volatile uh you
have to be where no
scientist and it reminded me and i told
him uh and this is a podcast that i
recommend you go on
by the name james altucher far more you
should i i i was invited
you should do it it's far better than
this podcast it's already planned okay
great
so james and i did a ted talk together
and he
i mean he did one and i did one the same
day and in his ted talk he brought up
some data and he said that children
smile or laugh 300 and plus times per
day
and guess how many times per day an
adult laughs it's only like six
and i felt like that's kind of what
happens with with with people in terms
of curiosity
in the in the i have a kid he's young
and he just keeps asking like can you
push in a black hole what happens if he
puts a black hole into the center of a
galaxy could you
do galactic engineering i'm just like
event even i
can't answer these questions so i refer
them to my you know colleagues in string
theory
you know that's the making of a real
physicist so i'm i'm
it's wonderful to hear that yeah the
child has the potential send him
to harvard i will but he's he's got his
heart set on uh on ucsd the
the the harvard of the west coast um
okay well i have to speak with you
okay you will yeah when we get together
next maybe and uh we'll get together in
beijing next time
uh last question i asked all my oh by
the way your colleague guess what your
colleague across the the harvard yard
said
he would put on a kamran vapha what he
would put on
his monolith to last for a billion years
would be the equations
of string theory so i found that very
very
interesting and and uh and kind of uh
kind of curious but i
i love camera if you want to to
demonstrate our our
herd mentality that would be fine okay
um
last question now we're going to go
backwards in time we went forwards in
time a billion years we went forwards in
time with your ethical zava uh
now i want to ask you the last question
sir arthur c clarke had these famous
three laws the first one is and i think
you mentioned this
uh any advanced technology sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic that's
number one
uh obviously if umumu is true they
actually did create some
beings created basically it's a magical
device number two
is for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert i feel like
you know we have this notion of listen
to scientists and like scientists
we don't agree if you ever find a
scientist right avi if you find a
scientist
and that person says you have to listen
to me you must obey me i i think
you and i have a rebellious spirit but
even the common scientists would say
go to hell you know i don't have to obey
you or listen it should be
the the the the way to decide things in
science is based on evidence
and data if there are conflicting
interpretations you just want to collect
more
more and more data yes that's the way to
make progress
so the last question is uh his third law
says the only way of discovering
the limits of the possible is to venture
a little way past them
into the impossible and that's the
origin of the name of this podcast the
into the impossible podcast it's part of
the arthur c clarke center
for human imagination avi last question
if you could tell a 20 year old avi 30
year old avi
just getting started in your career
something seems impossible to you now
young avi
but have courage get through it and in
in retrospect it'll be the best thing
that ever happened to you what advice
would you give to a younger version of
yourself
yeah so the biggest mistake i made was
that
i you know i i i always have a stream of
ideas that come up naturally bubble up
whenever i hear
about the results and what is being done
practiced in a field and
uh initially initially i was bringing up
those ideas to the attention of the
experts
and listening to what they say and if
they said it's not worth pursuing i
wouldn't pursue them
but then i realized that some of these
ideas are picked up by other people once
they hear me saying them
and follow they followed those ideas and
they led to the most
interesting insights in those areas and
after it happened to me multiple times
you know
15 years ago i said the hell with it you
know i
you know i just wouldn't listen to what
people say the
experts very often dismiss things that
go beyond what they thought
and if you bring up a new notion a new
idea they would dismiss it
irrespective whether it merits attention
or not just because it's different you
know it's just like kids in a
kindergarten
whenever they see something different
they bully that something
that that kid because because he or she
are different
that's a sufficient reason to bully
someone and
it's true also of twitter right so
anyway so i learned this lesson after a
while and i lost some important
opportunities
to innovate you know in other people got
credit for things that i told them
uh but then at some point i said the
hell with it i
you know i would not pay attention to
what other people say and
just pursue what seems right to me and
if i'm wrong i'm wrong you know but
that's the whole purpose of tenure to
allow you
to uh go in directions that you find
appropriate you know and
somehow in university the system the
academic system gives
puts some confidence in you and says
we allow you to explore things that you
know in directions that you might be
wrong but
take some risk and the strange thing is
if you look at the
private sector commercial sector you
know companies like
google starting with bell labs they took
chris
they had physicists
think about blue sky research come up
with ideas that were not
conventional at the time and had a lot
of nobel prizes actually given to you
know people in bell labs and
now the academic community i find is
more conservative than the business
world
how is that possible you know the whole
purpose of tenure is to allow people to
to be innovative and go in directions
that others do not necessarily accept
whereas in the private sector it's all
about making a profit
you find a person like elon musk
advocating for some technologies that
were not popular at all at the time
and he is now the wealthiest person on
earth
and you know he did it because he
realized that if you take risks there is
a
chance of you making a huge profit okay
so how come the academic community is
not recognizing that
it must mean that we are losing a lot of
opportunities to innovate to find new
things
gravitational wave astrophysics was
almost demolished
because the astronomy community did not
support it fortunately there were some
administrators in nsf
that decided to support it but i
remember as a postdoc
i heard a lot of bad stuff about about
the gravitation
and the same about search for exoplanets
there are lots of examples
and i'm just worried that there were
many good ideas in science that were
lost because of this
and i'm trying to help to bring us to a
better place in terms of the health of
of our mission as scientists you know
being honest
straightforward making mistakes don't
worry about your image worrying more
about
nature yeah you know that's like that's
a
magnificent message yeah max tag mark
was on last week and he said you know
imagine if
twitter existed back in 1610 when
galileo
announced the discovery of satellites
around the planet jupiter
they would have said you know fact check
experts in the catholic church
have disputed this claim uh
i should tell you that i have no
footprint
on social i know i know we don't and
that
explains your productivity your h index
is inversely proportional to the time
you spend on twitter
right i mean if you look at the you know
again on the beach you know you see
the sand that you find on the beach are
seashells that were
grounded up yeah by rubbing against each
other and they all
you know all these grains of sand look
this look the same they look similar
you don't want scientists to rub against
each other and break up into pieces that
are indistinguishable
that's very bad for innovation yeah
absolutely
well avi i can't thank you enough for
going
into the impossible with me i want to
wish you all the best of success
where ever the book may take you and
since you don't follow are not a big
presence on social media
i will uh do my best to promote you
inside and outside
of all these uh video venues and
otherwise i will let you know when this
comes out anyway
for now i wish you shabbat shalom
because you must not work
seven days a week that's the only thing
i would implore you not to do you're so
productive
you get so much done but we all need a
day of rest i make i command my
graduates the only thing i
bring religion into the public sphere i
say you i command you you may not work
at least one day a week i don't care
what day a week it is
you need to rest you need to recuperate
but i know you're going into a very busy
period for you i wish you stamina
i wish you resiliency but i know you
already have it so i wish you all the
best avi thank you for coming with us on
the show going into the impossible
thank you for having me it was a real
pleasure
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
[Music]